let's pull up this next story here and
talk about the decline we got this from
timcast.com
u.s house passes first assault weapons
ban since 1994.
laughable
stupid and a waste of time and
apparently some republicans even joined
in to support the democrats banning
nothing
bill makes no sense no one knows yeah so
i think this is a really good example
not of disarmament right a lot of people
are saying they're trying to you know i
think luke tweeted this they're gonna
try and disarm you for their
depopulation agenda or something and i'm
like no
i think it's it's nonsense it's
logicless they're not doing anything
this bill
bans half
it'll like thomas massey pointed this
out the mini 14 receiver is banned but
the mini receiver mini 14 receiver is
also not banned in the same bill
and and verbatim so massey points out
the mini 14 with a pistol grip and a
collapsing stock is an assault weapon so
it's banned the receiver of any such
weapon is also banned but the mini 14
with a rifle stock is not banned and the
receiver venice weapon is not banned and
so he points out he's like so how is the
identical receiver both banned and not
banned and they have no answer they
literally just don't answer it it's all
political moves it's like obviously i'm
in canada but right after you had the
shooting in texas at the school trudeau
came out and banned um transfer and sale
of handguns or proposed a ban the next
day and it's like
why you're we're talking about a
shooting in another country using a gun
that's already banned in our country and
you're going to put a freeze on sale of
a handgun that are rarely used for
shootings in canada at all where we
don't have a problem with this
completely political and it seems like
the us are doing that too even though
sometimes i feel like you guys have
better laws around guns better
understanding and then every time i
think that your politicians go into
stuff like this i just gotta say it
every time trudeau does a press
conference he's it sounds like he's
trying to like he's talking to somebody
he's about to rape
but i'm not trying to be like when he
was like
we need to ban all the guns it's like
it's it's the voice someone has when
they're grabbing them like just relax
let me do this put down the weapon
yeah i'm taking your gun away from you
and then and then it's funny because you
guys you guys up in canada banned guns
like around the same time it was like
uvaldi right
trudeau announces their freezing handgun
sales and it was obvious it was a
response to a u.s news story but he also
had previously complained up in canada
that canada with with a trucker protest
is that american politics are seeping
into canada oh so true yeah and then he
comes out and it's like come on dude
spare me i think this assault weapons
ban is
a perfect example of what the democrats
are they will they they they have no
logic to their to their morals it's like
we're all trying to figure out what is
what are the rules and how do we live
together among the democrats and most of
the left it's just pure tribalism
so they're like we're banning guns
excellent does it make sense who cares
as long as you agree with thing
current thing current year currently if
there's a bill that is proposing to both
ban and not ban something you've got to
discard that stupid bill or at least
remove that section from the bill before
you can move forward you can't even vote
yes or no on something like that it's
going to be really funny when someone
gets arrested with a mini 14 receiver
and then they like sue and they're like
well
what's the logic there is the logic that
if it says it's not banned but then it
says it is banned therefore it is banned
you know what i mean like the negative
is stronger than the positive or
something how does that how does this
even work
i don't think they care yeah i don't
think they care
no i want to point something out too
because i think we have this tweet from
ian let me see if we can find it i don't
know where it's at yeah here we go this
is perfectly in line with what we're
talking about check this out
ron phillipowski
what was the name philip kowsky
says lauren bobert wants the house to
pass a rule to give her five days to
read a bill before voting on it
he didn't say much after that
he just said this thing
but you'll notice a lot of the comments
are people saying like this is
ridiculous i can you know i can read a
book in a day
but then ian chimed in
ian of course you should read it it's
your tweet yeah it should be a felony
for congressmen to vote on a bill they
have not read i want them under oath
acknowledging they've read the bill
before voting yeah interestingly when
ian chimed in with that one then you get
some unity everyone's like yeah actually
that makes sense but the crazy thing to
me is
there are so many people responding to
ron philpkowski
just making fun of lauren bobert for for
saying something that is quite possibly
the most logical and bipartisan thing
ever
yeah i was actually very pleased with
the response to this because like ron
has a ukraine flag in his profile so
there was a part of me that was like oh
geez should i just assume he's some
zealot and it's like you know what what
he said is just neutral i'm gonna
respond neutrally and then people in the
comments you see people with ukraine
flags saying yes this is actually a
great idea you see people that are like
i'm a christian conservative this is a
great idea like i said in their profile
so it's just a it's an american idea and
i think it's an idea that that justifies
or that supports like
liberty
uh you cannot have ignorance in jordan's
race
i mean that's just it's just absolutely
at least five days at least i'm shocked
that that wasn't a rule beforehand like
the idea that they're passing these
absolutely critical rules for your
country and it's like not even a few
days to decompress and think about it
maybe they can read it in one day great
can they think about it and really weigh
the moral consequences of the stuff
they're putting into your nation it's
worse than you realize because marjorie
taylor green pointed out to us there's a
giant cat butthole on the camera by the
way marjorie what a good job buddy
marjorie taylor green pointed out that
often times when they're passing bills
they don't even
have anybody in the room it'll be like
three democrats and three republicans
and someone who's not even the speaker
will be like oh we got a bill here it
says this and they go eh
uh it passes and so what they've been
doing is the freedom caucus has like a
watch where they go down and call it
they they call for like a roll call vote
or something where they got to force all
the members of congress to come back in
and actually vote on these bills
actually do their jobs actually yeah but
they're still not reading them that's
the crazy thing absolutely
unconscionable and people have pointed
out in this twitter thread as well that
this is something that should have been
enshrined in the constitution from day
one it just assumed that they would be
reading the bills because that was their
intention was like what how could they
never how could they not you know
i would like to see a i don't know if
you guys have any knowledge of like if
you could compare you know the beginning
of the us how many bills were being
proposed and passed at the start versus
now i reckon it's like a mass ramp up
because it's super easy to just like
roll out that rug right oh we can just
pass and do things every single day but
it's super hard to roll it back and i
don't think things were initially like
the constitution was put in place for a
country operating like this where it's
like adhd let's just pass things and
propose things all over the place every
day and not even think about it and have
this 24-hour news cycle where it's like
bam bam bam bam bam they'll also put
like a thousand things in one bill yeah
so they'll call it the money they have
less bills now than they used to but
that's because they've got 500 times the
amount of stuff in each bill yeah but
let's let's go back to what uh you know
we're talking about a moment ago the
collapse of an empire
there there's there's certainly no
country when the members of congress are
more concerned with fundraising phone
calls than reading the bills laws are
being passed that no one even knows
about the the omnibus spending bill gets
brought in in a like a like a wagon like
it's like a red
they brought it in like a wagon 5 000
pages so
when your country's doing that uh
i'll put it this way
ladies and gentlemen
our members of congress don't read the
bills
they're not there to vote on the bills
there's a porous southern border
so
first
we have no legislation they're not
actually doing their job
next
we have no country a nation with no
border is not a country that's how
that's how country has to find a nation
with defined borders
a nation is a is a a group of people
with shared history culture and laws
we don't have shared laws anymore some
states have disregarded half the laws
sanctuary city sanctuary states i got to
tell you i don't i think the u.s is
basically like someone took a figurative
mountain and just splattered it all over
the place and now it's a big random
hodgepodge of nonsense
so i mean look the constitution is
switched swiss cheese
our politicians don't do their jobs the
democrats are calling supreme court
illegitimate even though they're
functioning as the constitution dictates
doesn't matter
none of it matters did you see how
they're shipping um illegal immigrants
they've been bussing illegal immigrants
from the southern border to dc and other
big cities and they just called in the
national guard in dc amer miriam bowser
is it miriam
muriel bowser requested the uh the
national guard to those like 4 000
immigrants when i was in tapachula i was
meeting with a few immigrants that had
been deported after a few years in d.c
in the states because a lot of them have
their court cases in dc so they know
yeah i'll cross the border and i might
get kicked out because i have no
standing i'm i don't even qualify as an
economic migrant i don't qualify as
anything
but they know that they'll have to be
taken to dc to hear whatever case they
have for a few years and they'll get to
have a good time there this one guy i
was speaking to was trying to get in
saying he was attacked by gangs but
half of them are actually part of gangs
and just try to use a bad experience
they had with ms-13 despite being a part
of it to get in and he's like yep i'm
making my way back up again at least
i'll get to spend a few years in dc you
know waiting on my trial will be fun you
know i'll get some food and board good
time
i can't be mad about this because the
cat crawled in my lap and so i'm just
i'm you know peace yeah it's like
the story should be really disconcerting
and distressing but i just you kind of
look like dr evil though
someone said
good evening mr bond yeah i've been
expecting you
yeah people more cats adopt a cat one
thing that's really interesting to look
at
um beyond cat conversations
one thing that's really interesting to
look at is there's i think it's the
syracuse institute that cover it the
level of
what judges allow migrants in versus
which ones don't you can look at some of
the comparisons and there'll be some
judges that accept like 99 of applicants
and some that reject 99 and only accept
one percent it is actually just a game
of luck it's like going to a freaking
casino whether you're gonna get in or
not um you can compare like female
judges to male judges which county
they're in and it is has almost nothing
to do with the application that these
migrants put in or illegals put in and
everything to do with the judge's
feelings will there be people that come
and try and get legal or recourse they
get denied and then they just come back
and try to go to get a different judge
basically and they can get it in the
next time i'm concerned because what is
the the solution obvi
like globalization on some level
is functionable you know we're
expansionist by nature i think expanding
liberal democracy americanism whatever
the u.s constitution could be good but
like how do you defend
i know one way to defend a border that
the the romans tried i mean it used to
be pretty brutal and that's not soldiers
yeah yeah weaponry thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there